désolé, je ne vous dérangerais pas ici,
mais vos gens continuent de me dire que vous n'êtes
pas disponible,
vous savez que vous pourriez vraiment faire plus
pour cette ville,
ma famille a une histoire de philanthropie,
mais pour autant que je sache, vous ne
faites rien.
l'
énigme te demande
le tueur a laissé ça pour le batman pourquoi
t'écrit-il
tu es venu
j'ai essayé de te joindre
bon il y a le dernier c'est une question d'
ailes
si nous ne nous levons pas personne n'auras-
tu un  beaucoup de chats tout sur la
force
la chauve-souris et le chat
il a une belle bague ton nouvel ami
je ne suis pas si sûr que
je suis juste ici pour démasquer la vérité sur
ce cloaque que nous appelons une ville
tu en fais partie aussi
comment  est-ce que je fais partie de ça
oh tu n'es vraiment pas aussi intelligent que je
pensais que tu étais
meurtri
toutes ces années
tu m'as menti alfred
nous avons tous nos cicatrices bruce il est toujours un
vin
il est impliqué dans ça oh il n'est pas
impliqué comment tu sais  qu'est-ce
qui se passe avec delaney qui es-tu là-dessous
qu'est-ce que tu caches sele  na ne gâche pas
ta vie
ne t'inquiète pas chérie j'en ai neuf
ça peut être poétique cruel ou aveugle
mais quand c'est nié
c'est ta violence tu peux trouver
justice
la justice de la réponse
vient vengeance
[Musique]
allons avoir des ennuis
vous